en fait tous les jours tu regardes est
indiqué et ensuite le concept non non
moi si tu en fais tu mènes petit roi si
tu n'en fais pas tu mets pas de quoi
faire un câlin mes parents oui tant à
faire aujourd'hui
oui ok bah tu m as ta petite croix et à
la fin de la semaine tu te fais un petit
bilan avec tes parents
ok tu as compris je tairai expliques tu
as fais du sport par exemple aujourd'hui
oui oui alors je mettrais un petit port
ici ok faire du sport ici ok je faisais
les crayons de couleur du coup c'est toi
qui me redonne 4 un petit parti pour les
récompenser
réduire les âges des réseaux sociaux
playstation jeux en ligne etc et donc ça
permet vraiment s'améliorer d'un point
de vue comportemental parce que l'idée
du ramadan c'est pas juste de se priver
de manger
ubs est aussi alimenté sont l'âme son
esprit est ce encore j'utilise vraiment
de vaisselle possible je ne laisse pas
couler l'eau pendant la vision moi
j'imagine et jara un petit peu comme ça
qui coule et ajuste un tir
c'est un petit peu comme ça dans la
réalité mettre l'eau plus compris le
truc même les couleurs j'aime bien ça
fait très symbolique
après un mois de partage pas de
gaspillage vous rend toujours ce slogan
et avec des diverses thématiques faire
des petites piqûres de rappel comme ça
ça permet vraiment aux habitants de se
rappeler les bons gestes du quotidien